du rpr à l'occasion du 44e anniversaire
du débarquement allié en normandie le
président de la république a inauguré
aujourd'hui à caen le musée mémorial de
la paix devant 10000 personnes françois
mitterrand a souhaité que ce mémorial
soit un symbole de la réconciliation des
peuples
michel vial le musée mémorial de la
bataille de normandie lieu phare pour la
paix telle est l'idée force du sénateur
maire de caen jean marie giraud
l'initiateur de ce projet grandiose qui
se veut à la fois site de commémoration
de conservation de la mémoire et
d'exposition de l'histoire en
s'adressant aux représentants des 16
nations hier belligérantes et cet après
midi pour la première fois depuis 44 ans
rassemblés en ce lieu
françois mitterrand entendait lui aussi
exalté cette volonté de paix qui se
situe au delà même de la réconciliation
dans l'union de l'europe pas seulement
une union économique selon le chef de
l'état mais une voix dans les affaires
du monde
quant au musée mémorial conçu comme une
pierre fracturé le président de la
république y voient un acte de vigilance
de confiance et d'espérance car la paix
est menacée dès que sion j'ai la volonté
de puissance
l'esprit des tolérances et c'est vrai à
l'intérieur de nomades comme partout
dans le monde confiance car l'armée de
la démocratie est par nature man au
service de la justice et de la liberté
espérance car la jeunesse votre jeunesse
celle jeunesse ici présent si nombreuses
elle connaît et elle aussi elle pressent
le prix de la paix avant de visiter le
mémorial qui doit selon lui être plus qu
un pieu musée du souvenir mais un
symbole de réconciliation françois
mitterrand s'appuyer sur la présence des
jeunes des seize pays représentés cet
après midi à caen pour affirmer que
seule une organisation commune des
nations et des peuples rendrait la paix
durable